c'est dimanche il faut que le ballon ne
faut pas se lever en fait ça lui on est
dimanche c'est votre jour de repos et
c'est pas le mien parce que mon jour de
repos ce sera un 1er janvier 2017 le
dimanche c'est le jour des explications
et aujourd'hui je vais encore vous
expliquer une technique un truc pour
bluffer vos amis votre famille les gens
que vous connaissez pour bluffer tout le
monde pour les abonnés qui suivent la
chaîne vous remarquez que je suis
habillé comme hier avec le même
éclairage qui hier dans le même cadre
qui hier c'est parce que je fais cette
vidéo hier enfin moi je la fais
aujourd'hui
mais pour vous je l'a fait hier puisque
demain matin mais pour vous dire matin
je suis pas sûr à 100% de pouvoir filmer
cette vidéo de la montée là bas donc
dans le doute et si vous n'êtes pas
abonnés à la chaîne c'est vous ne voyez
pas toutes ces vidéos que je mets tous
les jours sur youtube pensez à cliquer
la fin de la parenthèse je fais très
bien les parenthèses ok comme j'ai déjà
fait dans certaines vidéos je vais vous
faire les faits avoue la mettant au
travers la caméra on va le faire
ensemble essayer de vous bluffer et
ensuite vous n'aurez plus carrée
appliquer la méthode pour bluffer les
gens à votre tour vous allez prendre
trois bouts de papier 3 post it ou trois
bouts de papiers que vous déchirer vous
pouvez prendre une feuille de papier
classique déchirer une bande vous la
déchirante roi et vous allez-vous trois
bouts de papier classique je vous laisse
le faire je faire maintenant que vous
d'ailleurs voilà ce que j'appelle trois
bouts de papier classique voulait poser
devant vous et vous les notés de 1 à 3
de la gauche vers la droite comme ça 1 2
et 3 vous voulez retourner tous et
maintenant vous les numéroter de 4 à 6
toujours de la gauche vers la droite
donc comme ça 4 5 6 et voulait poser
devant vous le 4 étant le plus à votre
gauche et enfin voulait retourner encore
une fois pour avoir devant vous les
trois chiffres de 1 à 3 celui de gauche
et en le maintenant voulais mélanger
dans l'ordre que vous voulez allez-y
mélanger mélanger mélangez vous mélangez
autant que vous voulez dans l'ordre que
vous voulez j'attends maintenant dans
votre esprit uniquement dans votre tête
vous allez choisir celui de gauche celui
du milieu ou celui de droite dans votre
tête semble dire lequel vous en
choisissez un mentalement faites le
maintenant et retourner le désirent
retourner celui que vous avez choisi
dans votre tête vous avez donc devant
vous maintenant une combinaison unique
je vous demandais d'additionner tous ces
chiffres entre eux si vous avez un 3 5
vous faites un + 3 + 5
additionnez les trois chiffres entre eux
et garder sur résultat dans votre tête
on a presque terminé vous allez
maintenant associer ce chiffre-là à la
lettre correspondante dans l'alphabet je
vous l jeu
10 et dimanche ça vous évitera de
réfléchir trop alors un ca des c2 c3 et
c4 et c5 et c6 et c7 hec vite hissé 9j
se disperser aux hells et 12ème et 13ème
14 au 15 et ça peut pas aller plus loin
parce que les trois chiffres le plus
gros con et notés sont 4 5 6
vous avez donc maintenant une lettre
dans votre tête une lettre dans votre
esprit celle dans le rang de l'alphabet
correspondait aux résultats vous aviez
en tête
vous allez maintenant prendre le temps
de penser à un animal qui commence par
cette lettre
allez-y prenez le temps il ya des
animaux qui existe pour toutes les
lettres de l'alphabet donc cherché
cherché un animal qui commence par cette
lettre ça peut être un mammifère ça peut
être un animal du quotidien ça peut être
un animal fermiers comme une vache ça
peut être un reptile comme les serpents
et les lézards trouver un animal qui
commence par cette lettre et vous en
avez un en tête maintenant un et un seul
et laissez-moi vous regardez vous
mentaliser parce que je pense que c'est
ce que je raconte je sais que vous êtes
en train de penser à un iguane et que
c'était pas si facile à trouver
d'ailleurs un iguane bravo c'est un bel
effort et c'est surtout une belle
réussite de votre part vous avez compris
comme je fais sur certaines vidéos
c'était encore une manière détournée de
vous faire un forçage mathématiques pour
aboutir à neuf puisque votre chiffre
était neuf et après j'ai appliqué ce
principe bien connu des cours de
récréation avec l'éléphante danemark
donc vous avez juste à réaliser le tour
exactement tel que je voulais fait avec
les feuilles de papier les chiffres la
même méthode
regardez la vidéo apprenez ça comme ça
refaites le dès ce midi où cette semaine
à vos amis à qui vous voulez et vous les
bleus feraient si cette vidéo vous a plu
partagez là mais je sais que vous
partagez rarement les explications et en
même temps je comprends je comprends que
vous partagiez pas parce que si vous la
partagez après vous allez donner
l'astuce à d'autres personnes si vous la
partagez pas forcément à liker et à vous
abonner à cette chaîne
abonnez vous à les y regarder là où on
voit la clique et voilà c'est très bien
vous pouvez également commenter pour me
raconter comment ça s'est passé comme
vous l'avez fait à d'autres personnes
j'adore lire ça là c'est un excellent
dimanche et on se retrouve demain pour
le prochain mentale vlog à 17h ciao